all right so this is a new portion we're
doing as well I think we'll probably do
like one a week of these where we just
sort of talked about like kind of movie
news and stuff and stuff that's going on
like I said mostly in film that can be
TV shows to just up that's on our mind
and something we definitely want to talk
about after we heard the news they are
apparently doing another secret of NIMH
movie not a sequel and it's not animated
technically uh it is a live-action CG
film of secret of NIMH and uh who's
doing it again uh the writer of Ice Age
5 oh no wait and get this in the
producing team behind the Brothers Grimm
that masterpiece no I'm excited but no
it gets better from there how did they
describe it in the article that you're
us something to the effect of a
hyper-intelligent rat runs into a
comedic troupe of other lab rats comedic
like they'll be wild and make pop
cultural references would be like word I
don't know yeah by the way but I will
say yes yes they were and hijinks ensue
until they become super smart and going
to killing spree
I added the killing spree part but no no
they might because they also want to
turn this into a franchise yeah they
they have hopes at least the article I
read of turning it into a friendship
because we already saw how well the
franchise element of secret name was
turning out with secret name to the
secret of the use yes timeless classic
oh and secret of NIMH three Timmy in
time oh you know that's what I'm gonna
call like the next commercial special
it's just the secret of the use cuz I
recall the one the quickening they'll
just always be like you know bad sequel
titles you will need the retaking so um
yeah I I'm always open I will say hey
give people a chance you know for
anything but just the everything about
this sounds really bad um if the secret
name is one of my favorite
movies it's a it's spectacular animated
it's wonderfully told and I do get this
a lot of people like what do you think
about it Rob uh just whatever he says
about secret of NIMH Edie ditto to that
um yeah no it's just you like it so much
I just let you go on about it but we
pretty much agree I think for the most
part ya know it's one of those films
where it's like I remember watching as a
kid and like I felt like you treated me
like an adult which I really liked but
there's another kid stuff to keep me
entertained you know that I think NIM is
the best but used to let an American
tale land for time you know they were
all dark and gritty and didn't talk down
to us really all that much but the
secret secret name especially yeah was
like I always look at that like how is
this rated G I mean there is like
there's like some gruesome no you rim
style nicodemus yeah there's like oh
it's like old critius boom yeah I mean
it's like they just squash them at the
end of that movie it was pointless but
yeah um but ya know it's one of those
like gruesome gruesome family films uh
but it still balances out because it has
such a good uh main character and it is
completely timeless you can watch that
movie and my time in a Friday will be
dated I was talking to a friend about
this a couple weeks ago cuz he hadn't
seen secret of NIMH and I kept racking
my brain to try to find another example
but unless I'm wrong and maybe there's
an example out there but I couldn't
think of it off the top of my head it is
the only animated feature starring as
the protagonist a single mother it's not
about the kids it's not about the dad
house a single mother the muppets
usually dead in the movie yeah and I'm
just like and that may be the only one
at least as an American film I couldn't
think of another one off the top of my
head I was like going through all the
Disney movies I was going through even
other blue films and I'm like you know
even some of the Warner Brothers stuff
I'm like I can't think of one yeah no it
is a I mean this is one of those films
like I could do a commentary on I loved
it so much I mean I could just talk
forever about this movie uh and here's
the thing the idea of doing like a
remake or whatever
even a live-action one or CG enemy
whatever you want to do um it is based
on a book and the book does have
differences I don't even think like the
the stone was in the book I don't like
the supernatural element was not in here
who don't like the movie don't like it
because it added that element yeah so I
I have now you could do it closer to the
book yeah but but ice a writer of Ice
Age 5 just somehow get the impression
from the description I read and the team
they're putting together that if it's
closer to the book that's just a happy
accident I don't think they care so I
mean I Brothers Grimm I've seen and I
love Terry Gilliam but there's not a
good movie and even he admitted that he
took that that directing thing because
he just needed a job yeah he said
Leonelli che said I read the script I
didn't like it but I needed a job so
insert Terry Gilliam laugh hero yeah uh
so yeah I mean it's and it's not a good
movie
um but yeah and the idea the idea of
trying into a franchise I really don't
get so it's I'm not saying it in Ewing
secrets of NIMH yeah uh how many secrets
of NIMH are there um but yeah so it's
one of those things where it's like it's
not that it can't work it's that a it's
very unlikely it'll be anywhere as good
as the anime one the waiting is possible
and be given this set up it's very
unlikely that'll be good at all um I'll
tell you this I think you were way more
kind to it I'm normally the first to be
like well we didn't see you can never
predict that I
it's like Spock at the end of that
Abrams Star Trek we're about no not this
time
this is not this time I'm like I have
zero faith in this like reading the
description normally I'm just like him
because the example here would be James
Gunn guardians of the galaxy yeah the
guy who wrote scooby-doo and that movies
terrible I know some people like now
it's a sad tyrant Smith it is now too
now to be fair that movie was starting
off as an adult satire yeah
so again you could kind of eraill the
studio boys who the hell knows if it was
James Gunn's fault or if that was the
director of the studio or too many notes
from executives or you know focus groups
so you know that's the example but let's
be honest here I love guardians of the
galaxy it was my favorite movie last
year well we're not aiming for high art
with guardians again like this is a good
fun dumb ridiculous awesomely
entertaining comic-book movie you know
if you had said yeah we're getting the
team together that did the scooby-doo
movie and transformers and we're giving
them the Diary of Anne Frank no yeah
it's not that that's in quite gel is it
is it possible sure that Dumb and Dumber
one-in-a-million chance and then Jim
Carrey's like so you're saying there's a
chance like yeah if you want to go that
route but the quote Robot Chicken it's
very unlikely unlikely um so the the
only way I can see this like being like
like being good is yeah just trying as
best you can I guess to stick to the
book is at the very least you can have
people that say well Lisa's closer to
the book um but the whole idea I just
see like Stewart little like that shitty
movie that they did the guy did Han
Mansion did that and it's like you know
I can just see like mrs. Brisby like
wearing khakis like a sweater and just
being like I don't get it so Timmy will
be voiced by Michael J far I me and it's
or no way this would be more like a
prequel so you know mr. Brisby it's one
of those where it's light on it then
yeah if someone was just to say the bare
bones like this is what this story is
about back in the 80s when it was made
like it sounds like the movie they
usually would have made the 80s is going
to be made now you know it dump Bluth
did not step in and say hey I want to
make this a really serious good good
film that actually treats kids as very
adult but according to the chart we need
them to be more hip well and it's you
know secret NIMH is not it's not a story
that's demanding to be remade and I
don't it obviously has like a cult
following but I can't see it like enough
where it would really be like hey this
can equal Big Bob
only way I could see it remade is if you
gave it to a Brad Bird somebody in Pixar
who's taking this seriously or European
animation outfit but to let MGM just be
like yeah we're gonna do live-action
humans with CGI rats like Alvin and the
Chipmunks and no
yeah that's here like I think of - I
think of Alvin the chipmunk no no no no
no a fourth sequel coming out by the way
eight we got a franchise with chipmunks
we got this story about rats crossover
maybe that is it maybe that's that's the
endgame that I'll be the animated Road
rodent equivalent of Freddy vs. Jason or
the Avenger brings me versus Alvin will
win the chip vengers this is Alvin and
the Chipmunks II this weekend and after
coming out of something like that and to
come home and read about this well it
was like that scene a few good men where
Jack Nicholson just looks at the mall
with such contempt he's like you fucking
people like you just all the dreams son
yeah it's just like that's all I could
think it's just like seeing and that
came out of Europe um that was an Irish
I don't know how they do it in Europe
like I would say it's Irish but when you
look at the credits like 8 billion
different groups from different country
laid but so that was an amazing movie
and I'm just like in a 2d animated film
that was incredible like if if you get a
chance see it go see it it's only
showing it like art house theaters but
so to see something like that and just
be jealous I mean I am right now jealous
of what's going on
outside of the United States when it
comes to animation but there's a good a
like we to get stuff like the lego movie
and stuff but it's all 3d I'm talking
about $2 - oh yeah the medium we fucking
invented we invented it and nothing out
here like I'm super jealous like a thing
the closest we have is gravity falls and
vetch it's not like them
it's true I was arguing this that the
closest we have to what's going on
elsewhere in Japan and Europe is on TV
which is fine I'm sitting on that not
mom
yeah our TV shows are great but like you
can't compare with the sort of budget
you could throw it like you know two
hours of a major motion picture like
Grammy Falls does not look like song of
the sea' or you know the classic Disney
Renaissance they are doing so muffle
they are doing an adventure time movie
and I i'm right i think it's hand-drawn
so i mean that could be i'm hopeful
maybe that could bring it back hopeful
cuz this is embarrassing really
embarrassing for us as americans and you
know american pride i'm like we suck at
this right now
it's and ron yeah yeah - diva lover for
movies yeah cuz it photographer who
picks are the 3d pixar stuff and
DreamWorks stuff is fine but that's all
there is like if you want to the
animation i have to go to all these
overseas sources to get it yeah where we
are but you know what it is maybe we're
slowly replacing like the hand-drawn
with stop-motion cuz we are getting like
the boxtrolls and Coraline yeah like
that maybe that's like the trade-off
which is like fair enough cuz that's
been dead for a while too but it's like
but he isn't stop-motion and I love
stop-motion and stop-motion has its own
magic to it
really 3d CGI is my least favorite of
those three mediums and there's great
there's people they're really still
racing out I mean How to Train Your
Dragon than some of these films are
gorgeous so I'm just saying if you're
asking me to choose I would say it's my
least favorite but I'm not saying it's
use it's very good yeah um
but even then like stop-motion like
there's something about hand-drawn 2d
animation that's just is this magical
there's just something about it and
we're missing that now and so to see
something like that over season being
like oh my god why can't we make
something like that here and then read
that news and be like CGI rats and live
action based you know and have something
as perfect as the old Don Bluth film I
miss fucking assholes you know and it's
funny cuz I think people are always like
you know oh you you always sort of pick
on Don Bluth for his later films and
stuff like that and I do you know that
that's part of what we do but I mean
it's like good it's not always his fault
I mean
unless people do well we don't know the
stories you know but uh yeah the first I
mean not just his early career but I
mean like those are some of like the
great anime films in the most unique I
mean they look like Disney but it's like
Disney with just this incredible edge I
even Bianca's Disney to be fair you know
the fairy tales abut like when they got
dark they got really dark and this one
was just like if the majority of the
movie had Disney Villains in it you know
that's why I always felt like what Don
Bluth it's like well yeah you'll have
like serve a good main character a side
character but it's like most of the
surrounding environment is Disney
Villains uh and it just had this
wonderful edge to it and this wonderful
maturity to it and this wonderful charm
and this innocence and like I said it is
completely timeless I mean those early
films are 100% timeless you can watch it
now
as opposed to when it came out and still
get just as much out of it as you do it
kills me too because considering his
waiter career recently and everything
okay he would kill to return to NIMH if
they were doing this seriously like no
we want to do an actual good movie
that explains the backstory behind NIMH
and we want to make a 2d animated I'll
bet he would jump on board that if they
asked him to I don't know if I want to
well maybe I do I don't know I again
part of the charm secret name is the
mystery I love that you never really see
um Jonathan in it I wanna tell I think I
need to see it I'm just willing to bet
if you're gonna do any someone like
Bluth who you know has gotten sort of
backed into some of these films later in
his career like he may look at that and
be like me and I would jump an
opportunity like that but don't we need
our CGI rats
the only way I could see it work and
it's like I pray they go down this route
it's unlikely but I can see possibly
like you know if they make the the mice
and the rats and all the animals and
stuff look actually very realistic and
still keep it kind of quiet and kind of
dark because that was even though they
look like Disney characters in the anime
one uh there was still sort of this
brutal darkness to it and I think you
could still kind of do that and you know
it show this harsh world if you made
them look realistic and you made the
animals you granted they talk but they
don't move very realistic um and you
just keep that harshness to it uh that's
only I can see it working I'm as dark
and gritty just doesn't guarantee like
you could you could do it like that it
could still be a crap story well no but
it's at least be a step closer to you
know something at least what the
original source material was I don't
know Oh can't I'm I'm trying because as
I said guardians of the galaxy this year
is the poster child for don't judge a
book by it's cover but man I'm normally
so forgiving him like Wayne see I'm the
same way Batman vs Superman ever he's
like either like it's gonna be awesome
Bert's gonna be hated what do you think
I'm like a win see wait and see better
fights gonna suck I'm like well people
said Simon Mikey Dwayne sees this one
just I can't you just can't I'm a touch
more open but but not much I am oh you
did cuz I saw your original post and you
were open like well maybe even like this
and I called you up I'm like why are you
so kinda this is like well maybe then
when I told you the writer of Ice Age 5
the time I assumed there was he had that
like I'm on the phone with him and I
just heard this long side just yeah that
does sound pretty bad it sounds bad but
it doesn't mean it will be bad like I
said I'm still I hope I'm wrong yeah
really hope um so here's here's praying
to God that we can get something good
out of this that you know we can get a
good film uh but like I said I mean it's
got a there's gotta be a lot of effort
and probably a lot of fighting against
studio execs if you really wanna get
this film made and have it be good and
anything like either the original movie
or the book like there are gonna be like
fights up the wazoo with you know
whoever's financing it like this is way
too dark you can't do that you can have
a song yet to have them say a
catchphrase I'll be dated in two years
you know but it's it's not impossible
it's just very of like this is B ya know
like that that shit's coming I mean you
know you know that's like you know we
need another Alvin in the chipmunks
can't they sing a song can't they so
yeah Jesse you're the story about
fucking them Oh Bridge to Terabithia how
apparently the Disney executives
originally were just like
can't she live yeah can't she not die
author the the son of the author who is
pending the screenplay and I yeah I have
issues with a movie but to that guys
credit he's like no oh you get this
story like how does it's like doing
Diary of Anne Frank give me like can't
she live Schindler's List you know what
can't the Nazis just pass out flat
killing Jews like it doesn't work that
no one owns it to the credit of that
movie I don't think it's a good movie
but you can clearly see what they're
going for and yet today we will see that
he got his way at least ya know and
honestly but that's what they wanted to
do it like I could say and see here's
the thing I'll bet you the creative team
behind this will not be as strong if
notes start coming in like you know and
that'd be my guess - yeah I mean it's
I'll be honest I haven't seen Ice Age
vibe of it's anything like the others
which are just I don't think all fuck oh
yeah I think it's still in production
they're so goddamn many of us it's like
is it just it doesn't surprise me that
there's another I say it's like okay
watching maybe Baywatch maybe this will
be the surprise hit it'll be like the
guardians of the galaxy of the Ice Age
really no no really twice amazing you
wouldn't believe it I saw them it was
like Paddington that's how the first one
so Fitz of the second one they sawed
yeah I know there's people that like and
there's an audience and but fair enough
there's nothing like you know all that's
gum mess with your mind or anything I
was not it's I was into I've seen only
the first two fighting here John
Leguizamo is that fucking thing okay I
give you that Thank You Ven I give it
and I also give the point that it should
have really been the whole time about
what's this a scratch or the the little
squirrel
yeah the lone on talking squirrel I like
he's fun is is the first even he got old
as the movies camp as always two movies
I was indifferent to them so don't dump
all that hate on me like this but I I
didn't love him I didn't hate him I was
like they they exist yeah I even seen
three or four or you know friggin
whatever but I mean I guess why say sake
it's like it's not like oh my god this
is hurting me it's not that it's more
like just get what why am i watching
this if there is no point to watching
this right now we've got yeah in the 2d
world we've got
god oh the spongebob movie that only the
first few minutes of that are Andrew
Farriss is 3d yeah yeah no no wait what
we are best we can do is the spongebob
movie I've got less America no I've sat
I love to see another hand drawing I
know they're expensive I know people see
them those kids stuff I'm not getting at
your time well I've got people telling
me left already enough possibly to belly
got you have to feed it it's really
funny I'm sure it's fine spongebob to
begin with so it's not gonna make a
difference if it's not my if it's not
somebody's thing but you know even if
it's really good I would not like it's
not sacred Oh secret of NIMH spongebob
like you got a it's not gonna compare
well no and it's not it's not hand-drawn
uh if you're talking about 2d I mean
it's like I heard there was way more
hand-drawn than supposedly know that we
owe that the 3d portion is actually a
sprite which confused because I'm like
if I were all really and light CGI I
would have been disappointed going in to
find out that I was is the last I don't
know I hear different things but it
would have required me to go see I
actually won I mean I I'm not not a
spongebob person so I don't anybody
watch a spongebob is fine I don't judge
them it's just not my thing
I'm not anti spongebob I'm not crabby if
it's fine for what it is
Punch Bob is what it is he is a talking
sponge that lives under the sea in a
pineapple in a pineapple um so ya get a
little side rail there but uh that's our
thoughts of the secret is all we have to
look forward to is adventured yeah oh
wait I'm why you watch they'll make that
CG - way more looking forward to that if
they do that to DM Wayne we're looking
forward to that Elise and you know the
NIM remake or it seems Bob to electric
Boogaloo it's so it's so pretty how they
do it on the small screen I love to see
how they do it on the big screen so I'm
curious to see what they come up with uh
but yeah like I said just once a week
we'll talk about just any kind of movie
news or so on so forth and yeah we also
got on this nostalgia critic opinions
coming up - so we're entering a film
that right
so we'll see you there take care